there are many things to redevelop it
because we are talking about a very
early stage field but if I could
highlight three the first one and very
important would be to bring government
to the table to the discussion why
because in Brazil most of the products
and services that are being developed by
entrepreneurs meet the public search
service to be incorporated for instance
we have new technologies that can really
improve education in our country but
they need to be incorporated by public
schools or we have new management tools
that could help public hospitals to be
much more efficient but they need to be
adapted and incorporated by municipal
and state governments so this is the
first important thing that I'm looking
forward to to help building in the next
couple of years the second one is to
develop new financial mechanisms for
early-stage businesses but not
mechanisms that are offered today to
businesses as usual we are talking about
a different model of business that need
more patient money that need more time
that needs some adjustments that need a
lot of dialogue between entrepreneurs
and investors so these kind of new and
innovative mechanisms for early-stage
businesses are very important to me to
be developed and the third one we need
more role models all businesses are in a
very early stage so what we really need
is models that can be consolidated that
can scale that can inspire intrapreneurs
and investors to take more risk to
really believe that it's possible to
combine profit generation with social
impact and to reach big social change